hi everyone my name is bismi ranushi and
together with my colleagues amit sharma
and manushtameki we are going to guide
you through an introduction and
demonstration of the responsible ai
toolbox
the responsible ai toolbox is our latest
release on machine learning tooling for
accelerating responsible ai and it
integrates together several mature tools
in this space our agenda for today will
be as follows first we will give an
introduction to the release then we will
follow up by showing how the toolbox can
be used for debugging machine learning
models for counterfactual analysis and
then we'll jump to a demo on the causal
decision making capabilities of the
toolbox finally since this is an open
source offering we will wrap up by
identifying potential collaboration
paths within the toolbox as a research
platform before we start i'd like to
thank our team that is distributed
across several microsoft locations and
groups in microsoft research and azure
machine learning the toolbox wouldn't be
possible without the research
contributions of microsoft research in
redmond new england india and new york
and the contributions of the ether
committee and the great engineering and
design work that was led by azure
machine learning and the teams in ethics
and society so the responsible ai
toolbox is an open source and
interoperable framework for accelerating
the development of responsible ai
it integrates together several of the
rai tools that different microsoft teams
have built in the past in areas like
interpretability error analysis fairness
data exploration and causal decision
making
even though many of these areas
traditionally have been studied
separately in practice they are not
independent of each other and machine
learning practitioners may need several
of these functionalities to fully
identify diagnose and mitigate issues
and also to take actions in the real
world
to provide end-to-end fluid experiences
the rai toolbox allows you to customize
your own analytical processes in a
modular way and it considers each of
these pieces on data exploration
interpretability as building blocks for
the workflow
we will see together that the workflows
are highly interactive but they can also
be used together with machine learning
code in python
so instead of considering these aspects
as independent components which may lead
to experience fragmentation it is now
possible to build all workflows with
very different lego pieces and you can
adjust that workflow according to the
domain or the problem that you are
investigating there are two main types
of responsible ai workflows either for
the purpose of debugging machine
learning models or for causal decision
making to take actions in the real world
debugging workflows offer capabilities
around error identification diagnosis
and mitigation for example you might
have initially built a model you want to
understand how the errors are
distributed then you may want to
diagnose the errors either through data
exploration or explanations or
counterfactuals and based on these
insights then you may want to take an
action to mitigate them the causal
decision making workflows instead often
start with just interactive data
exploration and then we are integrating
brand new capabilities on cause of
inference by leveraging well-known
libraries on counterfactual generation
and also by using the economy and do y
libraries
so without further ado let me guide you
through the machine learning debugging
scenarios using the responsible ai
toolbox in this demo we are going to
debug together a machine learning model
that was trained by using the uci income
data set the task of the model in this
case is to predict whether an individual
is earning more or less than fifty
thousand dollars a year by using
features such as education world class
age and so on and so forth here we are
training a model using five estimators
in the ensemble for a light gbm
classifier
and then we are giving this model as an
input to the dashboard along with the
training data and the test data
then it's also possible to configure on
the dashboard by using different
components in this particular case i'm
using an explainer component
counterfactuals and error analysis
so um let's see how the um
dashboard
surfaces this information to the data
scientist practitioner
here we see that um the first component
in the workflow is focused on error
identification and we're using this from
error analysis we can see that the
overall error rate for the test data set
is 19
however through this three visualization
we can also see that the error rate
dramatically increases for individuals
who are married they have a high number
of education years but a lower capital
gain
and so since this seems to be
problematic then i'm going to save this
course for later use for example i'm
going to take this one on married
individuals
and also this one
on
married individuals that have a low
capital gain
and high
education
yet another action that i can take on
error identification is to slice the
errors based on perhaps sentence
sensitive features and attributes that
i'm interested in for example i can look
at
how errors are distributed across gender
and
number of education years
and i can see that as the number of
education years increases the
performance of the model becomes worse
and in fact this seems to be more
problematic for male individuals rather
than female having all this information
presented then next i may want to
understand better what types of errors
the model is making in these different
cohorts and in overall and i can go to
the next component
and i can see that in fact for the two
cohorts that i created earlier the ratio
of um the number of the false negatives
seems to be higher so there is a lot
more false negatives here meaning that
the model in this case is
underestimating the income of these
individuals
so this is yet another information and
now i may want to continue to diagnose
this process and i may want to
understand the data distribution better
and try to understand if perhaps there
is some sort of class imbalance in the
data so now i'm going to the data
explorer trying to understand the
distribution
and i can see that in fact for the whole
data there is an obvious imbalance there
are more individuals earning less than
50k
and when i go and look at the
distribution for the other cohorts i can
see that this imbalance now goes into
the opposite direction and this may um
explain the fact that there are more
false negatives and the drop in accuracy
in this particular
data which gives me insights in case i
want to augment the data in the future
perhaps i should focus on augmenting or
even or adjusting to this data
distribution better
next again in the diagnosis process what
i can do is to go and look at the most
important important factors that the
model is using in order to take these
predictions overall and i can compare
them across different cohorts for
example here i can see that the marital
status and number of education years
seem to be important in overall i can
also look at the direction through which
this importance flows for example i can
see that the lower the number of
education years the more likely this
individual is to earn less than 50k as
you can see the whole end-to-end
workflow exposes the user to different
angles of the data and the model story
and also it's possible to customize this
workflow according to the problem for
example i can easily remove one of the
components here or if i'm interested for
instance to look at the raw data here i
can add another component
in between in the workflow in order to
look at the raw data for example if i
click around here then here i'm going to
see the data in this cohort i can
generate particular um local
explanations for these records and try
to compare them with each other and
perform um instance level debugging
now um instance level debugging can be
even more powerful through the
generation of what deep counterfactuals
and amit sharma next is going to explain
you how it works and how it can be
useful for your debugging processes
thank you basmira i'm amit sharma and
i'll talk about how instance level
debugging and explanation can be done
using what if counterfactuals
what if counterfactuals allow us to
perturb features and observe how the
model's prediction changes so this is a
very common requirement when we are
analyzing machine learning models we
want to know if i change this feature
how would the model react
in addition uh what this tool allows you
to do is to do it automatically so you
could say i have a point i want to know
what features to change to change its
prediction right and this necessary
feature that may be useful for you to
understand what is the kind of input
that is driving the model's prediction
let me explain it using an example so
imagine you have a point here
which actually has a prediction of uh
less than 50k right
and this visualization actually allows
you to look at many different points but
now let's just focus on this one right
you may ask the question
what features need to change such that
the model's prediction now
changes and the more the person is now
predicted to be richer
so the first thing that we can see using
this tool is an overall summary of what
features the model things are important
here
of course the first one that comes up is
capital gain no surprises there you have
more capital gain means your income will
also increase but the second one is a
cause of concern
it's also saying that in sometimes
changing marital status perhaps in
combination with capital gain may also
help you with your income now of course
this could raise fairness concerns but
also be a problematic feature if it's
capturing some kind of correlation
so to drill deeper we can now look at
the individual data points right
so now we are literally looking at a
data point which is given here as the
first row and then asking the what if
simulation right so here you can see for
example if you have the same person but
with only two features changed their
capital gain increases and their magical
status changes uh then they would be
classified as richer but interestingly
that's not required even if you just
have a capital gain but a slightly
higher capital gain you'd still be
predicted as positive so these analysis
already helps you understand what kind
of changes the predictive model is
looking at and it can help you
understand also better
what kinds of bugs your model might have
one of the benefits is that now you can
start thinking about what are the other
features that might be important right
so this tool allows you to say what
features should be kept constant and
what features can then be changed to
allow more insight
to save us some time i've pre-computed
one such analysis
so suppose you thought that capital
gains is obvious right let me just
remove that so now you ask a different
what if question you ask
what if the capital gain remains the
same but now i want to see if other
features can tilt the balance and still
make this person predicted to be rich
right so here's an example
let's take a different person now
this person also has been predicted as
low income
and what you see now is capital loss
becomes the most important feature again
no surprises but let's drill down and
see what we learn from the actual
counterfactuals
wow here's something surprising
as you can see the original person had a
capital loss of zero
and this model
is saying that if you increase the
capital loss so for example the example
three shows that if you increase the
capital loss to 3000
then the model will predict that the
income should be higher now that's
nonsense right you would all agree loss
is bad but i think what's happening
really is that the model has captured
some correlation uh perhaps only the
rich people tend to have capital losses
and that's been captured here and so you
can see how this simple tool the simple
what-if analysis has helped you capture
different kinds of errors and explain
your model
this functionality is powered by an open
source toolkit called dice which
generates diverse counterfactual
explanations for any machine learning
model and it helps us achieve twin
objectives of both explaining a model
as well as debugging a model as i showed
you we have the option of including user
constraints which helps you customize
the generated counter factuals and you
can choose from a bunch of
state-of-the-art methods for generating
uh your counterfactuals with that i want
to say that while dice supports what-if
simulations it is still reflective of
the correlations that the model has
learned
for decision making we need something
more we need to understand the causal
relationships between features and
outcome which mirnoosh will describe
next
thank you very much amit you said the
context quite well as you saw the
previous parts was showcasing how
different capabilities like model
interpretability error analysis what-if
analysis data exploration and
counterfactual example analysis we're
coming together to help you analyze
validate and assess and understand your
models better but also sometimes you
want to take informed decision so the
next piece is talking about how we
incorporated causal inferencing in this
toolbox for you to take informed and
data-driven decisions and understand the
causal impact of treatments on
real-world outcomes so let's look at a
demo together so let's look at a demo on
the apartments data set where the
outcome is a actual price of an
apartment
and there are features like number of
fireplaces garage cars basement full
bath etc which are supposed to be
helpful in terms of identifying how that
particular house should be priced and so
your goal in this case is to understand
how changing these treatments say number
of garages number of fireplaces would
impact the real world uh housing price
and so in this data set in in this
example i'm just enabling the causal i'm
not passing any model there is no
machine learning model here and i pass
the model analysis object that is loaded
with causal insights to my model
analysis dashboard let's look at the
widget together upon loading this
dashboard you're going to see three
different tabs aggregate causal effect
individual causal what-if and treatment
policy the very first one is hoping to
answer what if questions about this
world outcome in this case housing price
and how that would have been changed
under different treatments and different
policy choices
for instance it can tell you that
increasing the number of garage
cars by one unit will increase the
overall housing price by 20k or
increasing the number of fireplaces by
one unit will in average
increase the housing price by 8k
while this is an overall understanding
of the impact of that particular
treatment on the price
this is here to help you understand and
personalized intervention and an
individual intervention so how about
this particular house what's going to
happen to this house if i perturb any of
its features in the real world how the
housing price will be impacted
and finally there is a treatment policy
that helps you build policies for future
intervention
you can kind of identify what parts of
your sample experience
has the largest response to the change
in the causal effect causal features or
treatments and so if i want to explain
it on this example imagine you wonder
for what houses you need to expand or
create or make a screen portion for what
houses it's better to remove it and so
this is your customized uh
intervention policy for you for houses
with overall condition less than this
value and in small lots
the recommendation is to decrease so
expand create screen porch versus if the
lot frontage is small and the overall
condition is low then the recommendation
is to remove or decrease and so that
might make sense in that sense that if
the lot is quite big
then it makes sense to increase and
create a screen porch but if you already
have a small and old
house or or lot then the recommendation
is not to expand it but also remove it
and similarly on the second row of this
table you would see that if the floor
footage or the square footage of the
house in the main level is less than a
value even if the condition is good
the recommendation is to decrease or
remove the screen porch versus when the
actual square footage of the main floor
is big uh or larger this value and the
house has a good condition then the
recommendation is to add the screen
porch so
that is helping you to understand that
oh if i just go by the default of i need
to create screen port for all the house
that's how much an average gain you will
see in the real world uh housing price
boost and if you go with this
recommended policy that you saw in this
table as you can see that the housing
price will be boosted even more and one
final thing to notice is there is a
table here which has been sorted based
on the effect of recommendation and so
i'm now seeing the first 10 houses which
has the largest response to either
removing or adding a porch and so if you
have limited and finite resources you
can only go with the houses that are
more receptive to that particular
treatment feature and one thing to bear
in mind is of course adding or removing
a screen porch in this data set has an
expense has a fee or cost and so this
also helps you kind of balance that
what is that
impact that you're going to see by
spending that money versus the effect
that you hope to see based on this
causal analysis under real housing price
and truly choose whether that is worth
it for you the functionality that i
represented in this demo is backed by an
open source package called economil
really recommend you to check that out
it's a python package that applies the
power of machine learning to estimate
individual causal responses
so to summarize this is a toolkit that
brings together all of our previously
released capabilities under one roof
hoping to help you assess understand
and evaluate your models and also make
informed data-driven decisions
we chose to build it in the open source
because we always love and welcome
community collaborations so we truly see
that as a platform where you can come
and plug in your own research and
modules and visualizations and sample
notebooks so please join us to co-create
the next stage of this toolkit expand it
together and also we always welcome
github issues and feature requests from
you thank you very much for your
attention